as you might expect President Biden is
blissfully unaware today he called the
lid at 1006 a.m presumably so he could
bask in the Caribbean Sun the president
is on vacation after all keep in mind
this comes after a recent Beach vacation
to the luxurious Kiowa Island in South
Carolina and then another relaxing
vacation in Nantucket along with around
60 mini vacations to Delaware this year
alone so with Joe taking up so much time
to recharge just who is actually running
the show well it's certainly not Biden's
Transportation secretary mayor Pete it
took Pete four whole days to respond to
the ongoing travel crisis caused
primarily by Southwest Airlines now one
prominent Democrat Nina Turner is
voicing concern quote what's happening
with railroads Airlines and the supply
chain is a result of small city mayor
being made the secretary area
transportation as a means to Pat his
resume for president secretary Buda
judge is a prime example of following up
joining us now with more are two
Republican members of the House
Transportation committee South Carolina
Congresswoman Nancy mace who was
directly impacted by the travel chaos
along with Texas congresswoman Beth Van
Dyne uh thank you both for joining us
tonight on Hannity
um I want to start with you uh
Congressman mace uh you had some
personal experiences tell us about that
but more importantly how is this going
to affect Americans and how are you
going to help solve it from a
congressional viewpoint
well not only that am I on the
transportation Committee in Congress
specifically the aviation subcommittee
but this hit close to home because my
kids my teenage kids got stranded in
Baltimore trying to make it home on
Christmas Eve and even today five days
later we still don't know where their
luggage is right now and so we've been
personally impacted by this in fact the
young lady who's operating the camera
I'm sitting in front of right now was
stranded in Denver Colorado for five
days luckily she made it home but didn't
get to see her son for Christmas and
still doesn't know where her luggage is
this has impacted thousands upon
thousands of people and I was
disheartened and disappointed to hear
the president of Basking in the
Caribbean during this crisis could not
be any more tone deaf right now because
this has affected tens of thousands of
people that can't get on trains can't
rent cars can't uh can't recoup their
flights to get home and they're stranded
all across the country right now I want
to hear Pete Buddha judge say he's going
to audit and figure out where the 7B
million dollars went that Southwest
received from American taxpayers that's
what I want to hear tonight
yeah congresswoman van dying that that's
the issue right I mean Congress passed I
presumably voted against it I don't know
maybe you voted for it but 1.2 trillion
dollars in infrastructure mayor Pete uh
you know they're handing out a lot of
money
um but I I he says he's going to hold
them accountable but where is he took
him four days to respond to this and
start making comments
well I mean it's not just Biden who goes
on vacation when he's most needed you
look at Buddha judge from the beginning
this guy was not qualified to take this
job he's a cabinet secretary and in his
first year in the office
where we're having tremendous supply
chain issues and people can't get the
supplies that they need when businesses
are going bankrupt where is he he takes
two months off for paternity leave
earlier this year we had our rail you
know the rail strike potential looming
over us we were going to have again I
mean a massive amount of of of hit to
our economy you're going to have
municipalities that couldn't get
chemicals to be able to treat their
water supply and where was Pete oh
that's right he was on a family vacate
in Portugal he could not be bothered not
to not to go on vacation to postpone
that for the American people this is a
man who was not qualified for the job
has never really been on the job and
we've trusted him with 1.2 trillion
dollars worth of taxpayer dollars and
you're seeing how he has just completely
fallen on his face time and time again
yeah it I I like that comment that you
know this is somebody in his career
that's uh Fallen up he had a failed
presidential uh run I don't see anything
that you know there's a reason why they
call him pothole Pete I mean what in his
resume would lead you to believe that he
could solve the major problems that
we're having with Rail and
transportation and and and the Airlines
and whatnot but you're going to get a
chance to grill him a little bit and
hold him accountable when Republicans
take control what do you hope to do
congresswoman mace uh when he does come
before the committee at some point
well we'll have lots of questions I know
on the oversight committee I'll have a
gav will be one of five subcommittee
chairman over there but on the
transportation committee he's going to
have a lot to answer for when he comes
to Congress what is he doing with the
taxpayer dollars that have been received
how are they being distributed how is he
going to hold Southwest accountable what
you're seeing today is the federal
government rewarding bad behavior by
having a private companies be bailed out
and subsidized by the American taxpayer
so what is Pete Buda judge going to do
about it besides hold a press conference
but this is one thing that I want to
make clear Nina Turner and Beth Van Dyne
are both absolutely correct on Pete
Buddha judge but this is what happens
you had Democrats in the left spend
millions of dollars against people like
me in swing districts who want to hold
the administration accountable who want
to hold agencies accountable so that
Republicans can't hold them accountable
it's really important to support
candidates like myself and Beth Dan dine
I hope that your viewers tonight will go
to
nancymace.org and support us that we can
hold the the administration accountable
when we're in the majority
well you've got your workload ahead of
you because there certainly is no excuse
for the amount of money that these this
Administration has been given but how
they spent it what they've done and how
they've done it go get them because just
next week you'll you'll actually uh have
the gavels in hand thank you both for
joining us tonight on Hannity
Congresswoman Nancy Mason congresswoman
Beth Van Dyne thank you appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else